I am super excited to have Clara Hemphill,
founder of inside schools here with us
today. She's a font of knowledge and uh,
it's exciting. So just a little bit about
Clara so you know who uh, who she is.
She leads the center of New York City's
New York City at fairs pop policy work
on economic segregation of
the city schools examining
why there are schools with
high concentrations of poverty
even in mixed income neighborhoods.
The New York Times called her three books,
designed to help parents
choose good elementary, middle,
and high schools for their children.
The most definitive guys to the city
schools in New York magazine culture,
one of the 200 most influential
New Yorkers for her work
in empowering parents.
Previously as a reporter,
an editorial writer for New York News Day,
she shared the Pulitzer
Prize for local reporting.
New York magazine called her writing
on the homeless worthy of Dickens.
She was a foreign correspondent for the
Associated Press and a producer for CBS
news based in Rome.
She has two children both now grown
and they both attended in New York City
public schools from kindergarten through
high school. So please welcome me.
Uh, please, sorry. Excuse me.
Please join me in welcoming Clara Hemphill
to talk about the public schools and
navigating the very segregated and
ridiculously complex New York City school
system.
Thank you.
Thank you. I'm really glad to be here. Um,
I wrote the first edition of this book
20 years ago when my children were a
three and one.
They're now all grown up and I thought,
Gee, I can figure out this bureaucracy.
I was a foreign correspondent in Rome.
I covered the Vatican,
which I thought was the most
secretive bureaucracy on the planet.
And then I realized the board of Education
is even more secretive and complex.
So I thought if I had trouble,
other people might have trouble too.
And I set aside,
I started writing the books.
Then a couple of years later, uh,
we set up the inside schools website and
we just released the fourth edition of
the New York City's best public pre-k in
elementary schools on sale on the back.
I hope you buy it. Thanks very much. Um,
the, um, why should you
choose public school?
Why to public schools matter?
And one of the things that
the last election showed us
the national elections is
how divided we are as a country
and public schools when they work.
Habs the ability to bring us together
to help us understand one another.
Um, and we need this public
schools. Now more than ever. Uh,
this picture here is an example of a
school that I think brings together.
It's those point base in Washington
Heights. Um, you if you know,
Washington Heights on the east side
of Broadway is mostly Dominican,
Spanish speaking kids on the west
side is mostly English speaking.
Kids dose Puente's brings these kids
together in a dual language program where
they speak, uh, English one
day a week, you know, uh,
half the time and they
speak Spanish half the time.
And it's a really lovely,
lovely school and an example of how,
uh,
children can learn together.
One of the things I like about it is
that the, the parents meetings are given,
sometimes they're given in Spanish
with English translation and sometimes
they're given Spanish with a,
in English with Spanish translation.
And one of the things I liked about
going to that school was having the
experience of being somebody who didn't
understand the language that was spoken
and had to have the translation.
So that's one of the schools and the book,
you know, that I can remap, recommend. Um,
public schools are just about the only
place besides jury duty and the subways
where people of different races,
incomes and backgrounds mix.
This is a Ella Baker school
on the upper east side,
which is open to children by
lottery from all five boroughs.
So it's not a zoned school.
It's a citywide school. Um,
and the, the, the great,
um,
Phil Educational Philosopher,
John Dewey at the turn of the last
century wrote that schools should teach
children to be social beings trained
for leadership as well as the obedience
train. So they can be voting
citizens in a multiethnic democracy,
not passive subjects.
Teaching them to be social beings without
letting the mingle with other children
do we wrote is like teaching them to swim
without letting them go in the water.
Um, I remember a, um,
talking to a Jewish father some time ago
who was choosing between a Jewish day
school. Is My mic on. Yeah.
Who's choosing between a d a Jewish
day school in a public school?
And I told him, yes, I understand
you want your child to learn the,
the reader about your
religious traditions, Hebrew,
your values are very important to you,
but if you send your
child to public school,
I guarantee he will meet at least one
child who celebrates Ramadan and a child
who celebrates Ramadan. We'll meet at
least one child who he interrupted me.
He said, yeah, I get the idea. I get the
point. And that clinched the deal for him.
Um, the, uh,
this is a PS 75 on the upper west side,
which serves both Columbia
University professor's children,
but also children who live
in public housing nearby. Um,
um, one of the great thing a lot of the
schools in the book are ordinary zoned
neighborhood schools. No
special application. You
just sign your child up. Um,
this is [inaudible] 80 in, in
Harlem. In some ways it's an,
it's an ordinary school test
scores are nothing special.
It's just sort of an ordinary school.
But a mother told me,
I feel like I'm part of a community and
a neighborhood in an in a way that I
never expected the pleasure of
making friends with other parents,
sharing babysitters and afterschool
pickups, even sharing holiday meals.
So one of the things I never felt,
I live on the upper east side and
I never felt I really lived in the
neighborhood until I had children
and send them to the public schools.
And there's something
about having, uh, being,
sharing the responsibilities of parenthood
with other people in the neighborhood
that really makes you feel like
you belong in a neighborhood. Um,
now I know some of you will say, oh, well
that's all very well and good for you.
And you live on the upper east side.
But what if you live in the
Bronx or in Central Brooklyn? Um,
one of the questions I got
ahead of time for this, uh,
talk was public school.
This is a quote from one of you.
Public School is not a viable
option for every New Yorker.
This parent was zoned for one
33 in district five and Harlem.
I cannot in good conscience
send my children to my zone.
School charter is also not an option
if you're against rote memorization and
some other very regimented tactics
they use to teach students.
It's true that there aren't as many
good schools in poor and working class
neighborhoods as there are enriched
neighborhoods and racial segregation.
Racial economic segregation is a reality
is those of you who are at Nicole
Hannah Jones, a talk sometime ago a
remember, but in researching the book,
we found good schools in
every one of the cities,
32 school districts. Not as many
as we'd like, but at least a few.
And we found some pleasant surprises.
You don't have to live on Park
Avenue to find a good school.
Um,
uh,
I also want to say that not all the
charter schools are rigid places where
children are expected to act
like robots. There are some, uh,
progressive schools where children
learn through exploration and play. Um,
and it, it's not, oh, not all
the charter schools are the same.
Just the way all the ordinary
public schools are not the same.
What about segregation? It's true and
it's really the shame of our city.
But even predominantly white schools
or predominantly Asian schools are
predominantly black and Latino schools
still have lots of different religions,
lots of different languages.
Um,
I was at [inaudible] 89 in crown
heights the other day in Brooklyn,
it's 97% black and Latino,
but the children's speaks
Spanish, English, creole. Um,
there's even some Chinese kids there.
There's a range of incomes.
There's a pediatrician, there's
a, uh, uh, a cab driver,
a home health aide.
It's a school that has served
generations of parents and crown heights,
and they have dual language programs where
children can learn Spanish and creole.
They even learn Latin. So that's
the school, which in some ways,
these indeed highly segregated.
And in other ways is diverse.
I remember going to an all
black school in, uh, in,
in Brooklyn and asking the kids what
they liked about it and they said, oh,
I love the diversity. And I said,
what do you mean? And they said,
oh, we have kids from every single
island in the Caribbean. Um,
another reason to choose a public
school is a kids need parents who aren't
stressed out. Uh, commuting
time really matters.
If you're trying to decide between a
great school 20 blocks away in a pretty
good school across the street,
I would choose the one across the street.
Another question is,
if you're,
if you're working 60 hours a week
to pay private school tuition,
maybe you're better off sending
your child to public school.
If working part time means you can
go on an occasional field trip,
volunteer at the school you may enjoy,
you know,
being with your child and at that
time, uh, it can be very important.
I also want to point out that education
is not just what you have from 9:00 AM
to 3:00 PM 180 days a year.
Just living in the city of New York gives
you access to resources that people,
uh, elsewhere don't have.
The natural history museum,
the Bronx Zoo,
um,
my children danced with the
national dance institute. Uh, the,
um,
there are huge numbers of resources that,
that you can take advantage of
just by living in the school.
Um, of course the argument about the
60 hours a week may work the other way.
If you're already working, I realize
I'm talking to Googlers here. Um,
if you're already working 60 hours a week,
you may want to choose private because
you don't have to be on top of everything
at school.
But what my point is,
is that consider your own convenience and
your own levels of stress when you're,
um, uh, deciding on school,
the children are made of rubber and
they can adapt to lots of different
situations.
Um,
another thing I want you to remember
is that no school is perfect.
As a parent,
you have to decide what you can live with,
what you can supplement at home.
Um,
there's some things you can fix
and there's some things you can't,
you certainly don't want to send your
child to a school where there's lots of
bullying or where the
adults at the children are,
where teachers have low expectations
and the children are overwhelmed by the
problems of poverty.
My children's school had physical
education just one day a week.
So what did we do? We
supplemented with west side
soccer league, which is a, um, uh,
volunteer. Moms and dads will
coach kids on the weekend.
They take up most of the park space in
the city and the weekend you've probably
seen them. Um, if there's
not enough math thrill,
you can have flash cards at home.
If there's not a foreign language,
you can take the whole family to France
for three months for the price of a
private school tuition.
It also depends on your child.
Some children in there, like a nursery
school teacher described this to me.
Some children like Dandelions,
they're robust and they can flourish.
And lots of places,
others are more like orchids.
They're delicate and they need
just the right temperature.
Some schools do a good job with
children with special needs. Uh,
others do not.
Um,
so it depends a little bit on
your own family situation. Um,
and on the uh, um, that
what your child has.
Like the most important thing of friend
once told me is to find a school that
doesn't kill your child's
natural curiosity.
A lot of what children learn
in the early years is not a,
particularly in kindergarten,
it's not cognitive, it's social.
Learning how to sit in a circle, how
to share, how to develop independence,
things like how to tie your own shoes.
The tone and climate of a school may
be more important than the children's
scores on standardized tests. Scores, by
the way, tell you where a school's band,
it doesn't tell you necessarily
where a school is going.
A school that's promising and on its way
up may provide a better experience for
your new child than a complacent well
established school that's a coasting on
its reputation.
Um,
so that's my pitch on why public.
Now I'm going to give you the sort of
the nuts and bolts of how to navigate the
New York City public school system.
The good news is that all four
year olds are guaranteed a seat.
And pre-kindergarten,
the bad news is it may not be in
the school closest to your home.
If you're willing to travel a bit,
you'll definitely get a spot. Um,
the applications open in mid January,
the deadline through
at the end of February.
But if you're looking for school
for your child this fall, um,
take hearts seats open up in the spring
and the summer for your child to be
eligible,
he needs to start.
He needs to have his fourth birthday
by December 31st. That means in,
say if he has a fall birthday, he'll
actually start pre kindergarten when he's,
uh, when he's three. Um, there, uh,
de Blasio has also promised
that he's going to have a pre,
pre kindergarten for three year olds.
They're going to start in
two high poverty districts,
one in the South Bronx and one
in central Brooklyn in the fall.
They haven't got money for anything
else. So, uh, I, I think, uh,
asking this, uh, uh,
asking the federal government and the
state for extra money right now is
probably not going to happen. But we
do a pre K for four year olds. Um,
not all of the pre kindergarten
classes are an ordinary public schools.
In fact,
most of them are housed in childcare
centers or private nursery schools or
religious schools. Um, you
can see the pie chart here.
The city's also opened what
they call pre-case centers.
These are standalone schools that your
child will attend for just one year.
We list some of our favorites in the book.
Um,
it's certainly a good idea to visit,
but most of the programs
we visited are pretty good.
So That's pre k elementary.
This is where the big kid school begins.
And this is when you're
five years old, you, uh,
if you are five before December 31st,
you're entitled to start school
in that September, most of you.
So for the,
for the pre K,
you're guaranteed a seat someplace,
but not necessarily in your zoned
neighborhood school. In fact,
most of you will not have a seat and
you're zoned neighborhood school.
Some of them just have 18 seats for
pre k and 125 seats for kindergarten.
So most of you are going to have to look
outside of your zoned public school for
pre-kindergarten. However,
for elementary school,
most of you are Garren or have a zoned
elementary school and your child is
guaranteed admission there.
Um,
one of the questions that you gave me an
advance was about wait lists. There are,
some schools have wait lists,
but honestly almost all of the wait list
clear and they ask parents to sign up
early and many do.
And they tell you that you're on a
wait list in March. But by September,
an awful lot of kids,
they've either moved out of the city or
chosen a private school or gone into a
gifted and talented program. So I would
not worry about, there's a couple of,
um, schools that have serious
wait lists in sunset park,
a couple in queens, but by
and large, there are, um, uh,
it's not going to be a problem.
Um,
the timeline is in, do I have
another slide for this? Nope.
This is the district's. Um,
the city is divided. Oh,
so I see the timeline is you apply in
November if you want your child to be
considered for a gifted program.
Um,
I'm not a big fan of gifted education,
but uh,
if you're zoned neighborhood
school is inadequate,
it's certainly an option
that you should consider. Um,
the testing for children for the gifted
program is in January, in February,
in by January. Then you submit
applications for other schools. Honestly,
the deadline is way too early.
Most people in the city don't know in
January what they're going to be doing in
September,
and they always almost always extended.
By the end of March, you'll find out
where your child's been assigned.
If you're interested in charter schools,
the deadline is April 1st.
Um, and then in April you find out
if your children, you know what,
I'm making this too complicated. Read
the book, Ask questions afterwards.
I can see that the eyes are getting
a little bit panic stricken here. Um,
zone maps,
sorry.
Okay.
The city is divided into 32 districts.
One of the questions was,
why are the district so weird?
Why don't they just make them
according to the voting districts?
The answer is buried in
history. Um, uh, the,
um,
districts were set up in 1969 as part
of an experiment in community control.
They were set up,
some of them were set up for,
they're all set up for political reasons.
Some of them were designed to keep
all the white people together.
Some of them were designed for, um, uh,
the keep give Puerto Ricans
power in East Harlem.
Some of them were designed to dilute
African American power somewhere in the
more designed to concentrate
African American power. The, I'm,
the reason you need to know about them
today is that your child has guaranteed a
seat in one of these in the
district in which you live.
And some of the districts are really
first rate and some of them are not ready
for primetime.
Um,
one of you said that the, um, whoops,
I seem to have missed the inside schools.
All right,
well if miss one of you said that the um,
the department of Education
website is very hard to use. Um,
we agree.
We at inside schools have been working
very hard to develop a new website.
We have a development now
we plan to launch and in the
end of May and I'm hoping
to get some Google,
um,
volunteers to help us with a guided
search that will go through, um,
help parents answer a certain
number of questions. Um,
I don't know what happened to that slide,
but um,
if you go to inside schools.org,
you'll see our old slide
and if you go to the, um,
ah, here it is, um, what we're
hoping to get as a guided search.
So instead of searching by finding your
zoned school or finding schools in your
neighborhood, we would also have
a ask a couple of questions. Like,
how old is your child? Um, how
far are you willing to travel?
Are you interested in a dual language
program for pre kindergarten?
Do you need care from eight in
the morning to six at night?
Are you able to pick up
your child after school?
That kind of guidance search we would love
to have some help with, from, from um,
any of you. Um, we have a couple of
other, uh, projects for volunteers,
which, um, she thought has
put on the, uh, Google give.
So I'm going to,
um,
the,
the best school guides and the inside
school guides are a product or projects of
the Center for New York City
Affairs at the new school.
We're not for profit and we
rely on donations to keep
providing this service to
parents.
So if you'd like to help us out by making
a donation or buying the book or both,
we'd be very grateful.
The New York City public schools
help make my own children,
the adults they are today,
intellectually curious, morally grounded,
every generous and able to get along
with people of all races and backgrounds.
We wrote this book in the hopes that it
can help you have the same experience
with your children.
So I will answer questions now.
Okay.
Um,
can you just go to the next slide?
MMM.
Okay. So I just wanted to let you
guys know that inside schools as,
as you mentioned it, they, they
operate on a shoe string budget. Um,
and they have a lot of interesting,
a few interesting projects that I
put in for Google serve for June,
some engineering projects.
So marketing strategy projects.
Really if you want to get involved,
I put a goal link inside schools dash
volunteer or check them out. Also. Um,
you know, I think as you mentioned, there
are nonprofits, so I put a gold link for,
for donations.
There's also books in the back if you're
interested in reading what Clarise book.
It's, it's fascinating.
Um, I also wanted you guys,
if anyone has questions,
please come up to the mic and ask,
I think where we can spend the rest of
the time on questions cause I know you
have a lot.
Okay.
Hello. Oh, thank you, Clara for coming
here. Um, I have a quick question about,
um, I know like many parents,
including my wife actually and,
uh,
six years ago I believe,
told me that if we should move to a
place where the school is nine and 10,
I said what? He's nine and 10. So the
inside schools or had the dynamic system,
they 10 and that's how we ended up
buying a house. There was long, long ago.
And now my son is five years old.
Uh,
so that was too planning
towards the ranking it,
but I still don't understand like the,
how the numbers go because that
nine and 10 became six and 10.
Then that became eight and 10.
So how I learned that it's not really
test scores. And how do you lead?
Is it worth like giving that
much weightage depending on,
that's a good question. We
don't, we don't rank schools.
It's our dread competitor.
Great schools.net. Um,
the difference between great schools.net
and us is that we live in New York and
we actually visit schools
and we base our, um, uh,
reviews on, uh, our visits to schools.
Great. schools.net uses two
year old, uh, national data.
It's a national website and it's
largely based on test scores,
which is,
as I said,
we're a school has gone
not where a school,
we're a school of span and
not where a school is going.
I think pest scars are um, uh, rough.
We have test scores on our website.
Um,
and I think they are a rough measure
of the quality of the school. Um,
if you have single digits of children
passing the tests, that's a problem.
If you have 80% passing,
that's a good thing. The um,
uh,
we on our website we have,
we draw the data from the
department of Ed Surveys,
which are given to a million parents,
teachers and children
themselves at the schools.
And the data that we consider important,
um,
aside from the test scores is attendance
to most of the children show up.
Teacher attendance to most of the teachers
show up. Uh, teacher satisfaction.
Do most of the teachers like the
principal respect the principles?
Do they work together as a team? So
those, um, those are some of the,
we have those,
that data for every school in
the city and we have um, uh,
qualitative reviews for
about 800 of the schools. Um,
does that help? Yeah. Yeah. Yeah.
So you mentioned you weren't
a big fan of gifted education.
I was just wondering if
you could expand on that.
Do you think the whole idea is bad or just
the way it's actually implemented? Um,
there are clearly some children who
need gifted education as there are some
children who need any kind of
special education and um, you know,
when a room of Googlers there probably
some very gifted children. I would, uh,
I would guess the, um, the,
a lot of what, um, if your child is,
is two standard deviations from the mean,
um,
he may well need,
he may need gifted education.
The problem is that the tests
are set up on national norms,
not local norms. So your child
might be two or three grade levels.
You might in the Bronx and your child is
two or three grade levels ahead of the
kids in the Bronx. Um, but the s the
city test wouldn't recognize that.
So there's almost no kids in the
Bronx who are considered, uh,
eligible for gifted education. Um, on
the other hand, if you're, if you're,
um,
and I think the tests also reflect a
socio economics as much as they reflect
some kind of, um, uh, curiosity
or, or natural ability,
the, um, in, in more
wealthy neighborhoods,
your child may be two standard
deviations from the mean and,
but everybody else is the
same in that neighborhood.
So that a district 22 on the upper
east side is like lake Wobegon.
Everybody's above average.
But that doesn't mean that they
all need gifted education. Um,
I can always tell when I've
got a real one on the phone,
the parents says that the child has taught
himself Algebra at the age of three.
Um, and he's having a little
trouble making friends and uh, uh,
it doesn't get an a in the
parents desperately want
their children to be invited
to birthday parties. That's an
example of a child who I think needs,
needs a gifted education. Now, if we
all had good neighborhoods, schools,
there wouldn't be, there'd be a very,
very small need for gifted education.
Unfortunately,
the quality of schools
is really uneven and, um,
gifted education is,
it is a particularly good way to get out
of a nasty neighborhood school that you
don't want to send your child to. The, um,
the other problem with the
gifted education is I think
children need to learn
that hard work is what matter.
And you're not born with gifts as much.
I mean,
you may be born with gifts,
but counts is how hard you work
and that there's a kind of,
in these gifted programs, there's
kind of a fear of, of falling.
It was a fear of failure.
Um, also I think, uh, the,
the tests measure a rather
narrow range of academic skills.
They don't past. If you're a
great musician, they don't test.
If you're a great artists,
they don't test if you're athletic,
they don't test if you're particularly
good at making friends and, uh,
ending playground squabbles. So, uh,
I want my children to be exposed to all
of those things and not just to kids who
do well on a particular test.
The other thing is I think giving the
test to four year olds is really too
early. I just think that
you can't, you know,
the predictive quality of these tests
is not that the tests are not that
accurate and the divide between the 99th
percentile and the 98th percentile of
kids at the age of four
is kind of ludicrous.
The other thing is a lot of what you're
learning in elementary school is not
cognitive. It's how to tie your
shoes, how to sit in a circle, um,
how to make friends, how to get along
with the classroom routines. So,
um, I, I, this is what I think
about early childhood education.
I think by third, fourth,
fifth, sixth grade, the, um, uh,
a very good teacher can
reach range of children,
but the wider that range is,
the harder it is for a teacher to,
uh,
reach that. Um, in my kindergarten,
what you'd want to ask of your of the
school is how do you challenge children at
the top and how do you,
um,
give help to kids who need it? And
your child might need both, right?
Your child might be a math wiz who has
trouble making friends or your child may
read way, you know, maybe meeting Harry
Potter and kindergarten but can't add,
right? So you, you, your child
can be simultaneously gifted and,
and struggling at the
same time. Um, my kin,
my son was very good at puzzles
and when he, in kindergarten,
he finished the hundred piece puzzle.
The teacher would pull down the
500 piece puzzle for him. Um,
when you look in classrooms,
you want to see a range of books.
If everybody's reading the same book,
that's probably not a good place.
But if some kids are reading frog
and toad and other kids are reading
Charlotte's web,
that's a sign.
If you look at the writing on
the board and you see some kids,
the writing five pages and some
kids are writing three paragraphs,
that's a sign that the school is
adapting to kids with different needs.
So of course you want your child to be
challenged if he's very bright and you
want them to get the
help, uh, if he needs it.
But that doesn't necessarily mean
he needs to be segregated, um, in,
in a classroom with other kids who are,
who are,
who do well on this academic test.
Um, so, uh, the school that we're
zoned for is relatively new.
It was just launched like
four years ago maybe.
So I think there's not a lot of
information on it yet. It's um,
the school for social social action.
Yeah. I know. 27 I think. Yes. Um,
so we ideally want to send,
our daughter's only seven months old,
but we want to send her there,
but we're being told by a lot of people
to keep our options open and make sure
we're planning for the possibility of a
gifted and talented program or a private
school. Um, so I guess
my question is two fold.
Like what are your thoughts on that and,
and knowing that our daughter so young,
like what are the things that we should
be thinking about right now to set her
up for whatever options, but ideally
wanting to send her to public school.
Are there things that we should
be thinking about doing now
if you could afford to stay in
district two? Yeah, I'd stay put um,
district to not only has
terrific elementary schools
that also has good middle
schools and good high schools,
which is not universally the case at all.
Um,
uh, then, um, I like five 27 a lot. Um,
it's a shade traditional than some of,
well I won't get into details
about individual schools,
but in your district I like five 27.
It's in the book, you can meet about it.
There's also a gifted program,
a flute few blocks away.
There's two gifted programs a few blocks
away, both of which I liked very well.
So what are there things we should be
thinking about doing know to like make
sure that she's prepared for like the
application process for gifted and
talented or for getting her
ready for elementary school.
Because I've just heard from people
like in the building who are saying they
send their kids to gifted and
talented and they're like, oh,
there's all these things you have to do
these classes you have to take to make
sure that they're, you know, on
the resume for like, yeah, I,
I think it's kind of sick. You know, I,
I want to like let children be children.
Right. And I will encourage
you to resist that. Okay.
My son, I thought he was
gifted, uh, you know,
he was doing the big puzzles and
kindergarten, you know, um, but um,
he was at the age of four,
he was still throwing blocks and the
thought of having him sit down with a
stranger and a pencil and paper test
just seemed insane, you know? So,
um, yeah, sure.
There are people who will charge you
lots of money to prepare for this test.
But I would strongly discourage it,
particularly because you
live in a neighborhood with
his own schools are fine,
you know, in neighborhoods with
his own schools are not fine.
I don't mean to trash gifted and
talented across the board, you know,
easy for me to say my kids went to the
local school and it was great for a lot
of people that gifted schools are
a good option. One other, sorry,
one last thing then.
If the baby,
you mentioned that the cutoff is December
31st there's a lot of theories about
keeping your child back or advancing them.
But it sounds like my reading showed me
that in public schools you don't really
have that choice. Is that true? Or can you
hold your child back? You cannot, you're,
you're stuck with the, uh, um, yeah.
So this is called red shirting where
you hold the kids back year of the idea
that there'll be bigger and
stronger and smarter. And then,
and it's the same group of people who
are telling you to get the test prep for
your seven months old,
you know, you know, um, I,
my,
I have a November birthdays.
My daughter was the November birthday
and she was pretty tiny for kindergarten
and she was pretty exhausted
at the end of the day. Um,
so I understand the, um, theory. Yeah,
I understand the impulse to, uh, I,
I mean I think it's actually their,
their political reasons why these things
are set up that don't necessarily have
to do with pedagogy or child development.
Um,
I hope the question you could ask
at five 27 or any other school is,
um, I have a November birthday, you
know, my child has a November birthday.
Um,
how do you adapt for younger children?
You know,
do they have a rest time?
Um, do they have, um,
you know, are, are, are they,
or can they accommodate a child who's
a little bit younger and, and, and,
and see what the answer. I mean, I
think that's a, that's a valid question,
but they won't let you red shirt
and I'm afraid. Yeah. Okay.
Yeah. Hi, I'm a couple of
questions if I may. Um,
first I love to hear your thoughts
on non zones district schools. Yeah.
Why do they exist and what steps can one
take it there a great one year by that
you want to get your kid
into. Um, and then second, um,
the school in my son appears to not
be a good school. I haven't looked,
haven't I'm going to buy your book.
Yeah. You convinced me. But I've,
I've looked at like at like a school
digger and the ranks are good. Um,
and so what, what's the school alpha
docs. Okay. I know. That's cool. Yeah.
I mean my kids are four, they're,
they're already signed up for preschool,
but I'm thinking about kindergarten,
um, for, you know, a year down the road.
Realistically,
are there things that I can do as a
parent who wants to be involved to really
make an impact on the school nearby or
it's my time better spent thinking about
how I can get my kids
into a different school,
whether they said the nuns zone district
school or moving or something else.
I love that question. That's
a really good one. Um, yes,
parents can make a difference.
Um,
you have to talk to,
you have to talk to other
parents and decide, um,
other parents and see if you've got
other people who can work with you.
And then you have to talk to the
principal and see if he wants you to work.
And it's gotta be,
you can't say this a terrible school,
we're going to save you and make it
better for some reason that approached
doesn't, um, you know, it's not
really welcome, but you know,
we love the school and we want to
support it. Can we do x, Y, Z, um, is,
um,
now district.
So some of the districts have
district wide school choice for,
so this is again, this is a, um,
hell's kitchen. It was right by,
yeah. And there's, there's midtown west,
which is a school that accepts kids
from all over the district. Um,
and um, supposedly by
lottery. Um, same as,
I don't know if you read the piece
in the Sunday Times about one 65 and
Manhattan school for children
and the upper west side.
Another case of a sort of unfavored
zone school and a favored cool,
groovy Boutique, um,
hipster millennium school.
Um,
and how they got set up was dissatisfied.
Parents who were zoned for the unfavored
school were dissatisfied and created
something new with under the
auspices of the Department of Ed.
Um, and, um, that the,
the use to these district schools use
to have their thumb on the scales for
parents who wanted to volunteer.
The last administration,
Bloomberg thought that was not really
fair. Um, I think there was one, um,
uh,
Joel Klein,
the previous chancellor may read in my
book where I said one family had two
mothers and they promise to mothers in
the PTA and that that got them into the
school.
Um,
and he thought that this kind of the
skulls chancellor thought this kind of
string pulling was willing,
not very nice. So we made it,
everything's done by lottery now.
However, after the first, um,
round of admissions comes out, the
admissions reverts to the local school.
And at that point, pleasant persistence,
you know, can make a difference.
Um, one pan, this the one 11 year
school. I didn't put it in the book,
but it's a, it's a, it's, it's,
it's moving in the right direction.
So I would give it another facet.
And I also want to encourage you to go
to inside schools.org and not school
digger and you know,
thank you.
Hi. Thanks for coming today. We love,
we love you. We're, we're a bit,
we're a big fan of your books
and your site. Thank you.
That's a general question.
What's like a trend that you would like
in public schools and wants to try and
you're not so happy about?
Oh, well I think preK is
wonderful, right? I mean,
I paid $12,000 for nursery school,
you know, when my kids were little.
So I think that's, that's
a, a wonderful trend. Um,
I think the trend towards
progressive education is a good one.
I think children learn through doing,
they learn through play,
they learn by putting together
blocks. They learn, you know,
engineering and math skills
with blocks and Lego.
So I like classrooms that have a lot of
blocks and lego rather than classrooms
for the little kids that have lots
of pencil and paper exercises.
I like schools where the children read
what they call authentic literature that
has children's picture books and
books that you might read for fun.
I think that's um,
uh,
the extent to which that's increasing
I think is a very good idea. Uh,
what I don't like is the
obsession with standardized tests.
Some schools have become just test prep
hell where the kids work for hours and
hours and hours filling out,
learning how to fill out bubble sheets.
Thanks.
Hi. Um, I have, uh,
maybe two questions this time about
reading between the lines on a school.
Uh, one question is how, how,
how do you determine if the
fiscal is sort of improving?
Cause you mentioned how it's not
about where the school has been.
Okay,
that's a really good question.
Um, in terms of a data,
I look to see if, um,
enrollments increasing.
That's usually a sign of parents
voting with their feet. Um,
I look to see if attendance is
improving before the test scores go up.
You've got to get some of the,
some of the public schools have very,
very high rates of absenteeism and that's
the sign that the kids are not happy
to be there. And um, so when you
see the attendance going up, um,
the most important thing
is an effective principal.
Um,
hands down,
a good principal will attract
good teachers and encourage
them to work together
as a team. A bad principal can
dismantle a good school just as quickly.
So leadership is all and you can usually
feel the difference within about a
couple of weeks of the new principal
coming to pound. So in terms of the data,
we do look at
teacher satisfaction with the
principal as one thing to look at,
which we have on our, on
our, on our website. Um,
and uh, the, the,
the, those are the signs that a school is
moving in the right direction. Again, um,
what I was talking to some schools
start in the schools that are improving,
start getting better in the lower
grades and build up one by one.
So if you see a good
pre k and kindergarten,
but the fifth grade is not so hot,
that may be okay.
It could be that they're
building from the bottom up. Um,
so look for the lower grades.
Is that helpful?
My other question that
are not quick. Um, uh,
so speaking of someone who's Lil B
be parents of mixed race children,
I'm thinking of,
um,
can you determine how could you determine
if there's the educational quality of
level for all children?
Because sometimes some schools we looked
at and I think some anxiety of like, oh,
they're rating on like school,
school crusher or whatever they're rating
on some other website, uh, is high.
But then I there see like
really significant segregation
at the gas levels of
other things.
So I worry about getting,
so how could you read into whether it's
a good education for all of the studio?
Um, I, yeah, I talked to parents
about that. Um, it's funny,
I went to ps 75,
which was one of my slides with the
African American staff member and I'm one
66.
75 is mostly black and Latino
and one 66 is, is mostly white.
And she felt right away sort of
a different vibe, you know, in,
in the building about how welcoming
they are to people of color. Um,
but a lot of the,
um,
a lot of the schools that are multiracial
do have lots of multiracial families
also because for them it's very
important. You know, if you have a,
a black mother and a white father,
you may not want your child
in an all black school,
but you don't want your child in an all
white school either. Um, so I would ask,
I would ask for the, um,
the, the parents, um,
I think a, a, a good, you know,
I should have brought our, uh,
I'll send you a link to our report
on integrated schools that work,
which is on the center for
New York City Affairs website.
And one of the things that really matters
is that the principal wants the school
to be integrated.
You'd be at the number of principals
who really don't care and are happy with
whatever the status quo is.
Okay.
Hi.
Um,
I'm in the middle of going through
the process with my four year old.
So it was just wondering if you had any
more insight or could explain more about
the waitlist situation. Um,
and how that movement works.
Because being in May now and I were on
the wait list at five different programs
and wait list at five different programs
for pre K or for or breaking yeah.
And our wait list now,
like when I called the schools were like
114 on the list and number 42 on the
list.
And since
pre k you're talking about,
yeah,
when I was being blessed say about
the weight lifts I was talking about
kindergarten, pre K it's a whole
different kettle of fish. You might have,
you know, 18 seats and
500 kids. So uh, applying.
So don't move or they don't let let,
let's talk afterwards a little bit about,
through your particular situation,
how do you manage between, so because
pre k is so different than kindergarten.
Like my understanding from everyone I
hear is that you have to go through this
all over again for dinner. Isn't it
awful? I do believe it. It's just,
yeah. And then middle school
and high school to even plan.
Like what pre k you would want to go to
if like for consistency sake for your
kid. I mean consistency is
nice. It'd be great. You just,
it's not realistic.
Yeah.
I'm mean I have, I talked to
parents who have um, you know,
private nursery school for third for
the three year old and then public pre k
for the four year old and then a
public school for the, you know,
when he's five and moving three times
since three years would drive me nuts. So,
you know,
I can understand.
I think continuity is probably worth
spending a little money for if, if,
if you have to, um, but more
for you than for your child.
I mean, I think your child will
probably adjust with, you know,
the pre k situation.
It's only been around for two years.
They created 70,000 seats practically
overnight. That it's functioning is,
is, is a miracle. And that there
are, um, uh, but there are, uh,
certain neighborhoods of the city,
there are just long wait lists and
they haven't figured it out yet.
It's shocking. Yeah,
yeah, yeah. Sorry. Yeah.
So you said several times,
you know, principles,
the most important thing and you said, you
know, the principal can make it happen.
Now this school across the street from us,
it's ISP has 38,
the Pacific in Brooklyn,
all the comments talk about trouble with
the administration and the principal
not being good.
And is there something that you can do
about that or is it just you avoid the
school or,
I don't know what,
um, parents can lobby to
get rid of a principal.
They succeeded at two 82 which is
in park slope not too far from you.
Um, some at 38, they're trying to
like work around the principal.
There are a couple of schools that
managed to build a cohesive staff,
an inadequate principle. But um,
then you have to figure out why the,
you know,
some,
some parents have also gotten rid of
terrible a district superintendents in
Washington heights, parents
United to get rid of. So um, yeah,
get rid of or work
around or the two answers
does, does working around work,
like what do you think? That's cool.
It can be functional or is it really it's,
it's kind of in trouble with
the principal like that.
I think you should talk to the
parents who were there every day. Um,
there are,
I agree with your assessment that said,
there's some parents who were
very happy with the situation.
I wanted to go back a little bit to
the gifted and a very high functioning
district school questions.
So I went to a public magnet school that
was amazing and it was a really good
experience,
very along the lines of [inaudible].
So at the high school level
and it and where I came from,
there was definitely a concept of feeder
schools that there were middle schools
that gave rise to most of the high schools
and their elementary schools like a
rose to most of the middle schools.
Is there a feeder school style
set up here for the high school?
Alas, yes. Okay. There are, um,
another one of our reports on the center
for New York City's Ferris website
shows you what middle school feeders
there are to Stuyvesant in Brooklyn Tech
and the, and the specialized
high school. So, uh, yes,
but you don't have to worry
in kindergarten. Okay.
I think, yeah, I guess,
do they tend
to be the sort of like really good
neighborhood schools or do they tend to be
gifted schools or is it a mix?
Okay.
Don't worry about it in elementary. Okay.
Yeah, call me in five years and we'll,
you know, we'll work it out, but it's,
I'm not pretending the system is
equitable and works well for everybody.
MMM.
We have three more minutes, I guess. Yes.
Okay. So, uh, I grew up in Europe
and I'm a lot more familiar,
but the school systems there,
a lot of things are different here.
Two things that we
haven't really touched on.
One of them was a that we learn that uh,
classes get new teachers every year and
instead of like one teacher taking down
throughout, I didn't know the
first five years of school.
Is that true across the board and most
public schools or are there differences
or what,
what's your opening?
Um, it's not the, it's not true.
Some schools have what they call looping,
which is I teach kindergarten this year
and first grade next year and then I go
back to kindergarten and then first grade.
So I have you have the same
teacher for two years. Um,
and if you put looping into our search
engine and you might find some schools
like that or in the book you can,
you can see some,
the other thing that they signed a few
schools have is what they call bridge
classes where you have both kindergarten
and first grade in one classroom and
you stay in that classroom with
the same teacher for two years.
So we do have some of that.
Rudolph Steiner School is private.
It's the only one I know of that
keeps the teachers for the whole, uh,
we keeps the kids for, you know, the
whole of their elementary school. Um,
the new American Academy might
do that as well in Brooklyn. Um,
I think they may have that European model.
You don't think there's real value in
data, right? It's just not common or,
oh, sure. I mean there's like any
of these things, there's, there's,
there's a advantages and drawbacks
and sort of other thing I wanted to touch
on is about the PTA where like people
as how they can get involved and
do something where to school.
I sort of want as the opposite,
like in Europe, like schools,
suburb can you can't get
involved a little bit,
but I sometimes feel there is like an
expectation or pressure for people to get
involved.
And I didn't even know.
This isn't like a private preschool that
parents who don't get involved are cold
out or it's like,
like I think it's,
I mean the other difference between the
United States and Europe is that our
schools are supported through local taxes,
mostly property taxes.
And in,
in most countries of the world,
it's a national system where
everybody gets the same.
All the teachers get the
same pay and the same,
the schools all get the same resources.
So what we do in New York City is we
have these insane PCAs that, you know,
raise $1 million a year.
Um,
I agree with you that it's lunacy.
some schools will pressure you.
Um,
some actually have a kind of
parents stay out attitudes.
So it varies from school
to school. Um, yeah.
I mean I agree with you.
It's ridiculous. Thank you.
What are your thoughts on dual language
programs and how effective they are for
a native speakers of English
are very good questions.
So we have in the, in the end of the book
you'll find a dual language programs.
There's a Chinese, Spanish,
Polish, Italian, um,
Haitian creole, French,
Mandarin. Um, there's even,
there's one in Korean as well.
Um, and some of the children,
the way they're supposed to be designed
as half the children speak English at
home.
Um,
half of them speak the other language
and they alternate the language of
instruction from day to day.
And the kids who are supposed to be fluent
in both languages by the time they're
in fifth grade, the um, some
of them work very well indeed.
Um,
it also depends on the language.
I think a Chinese and Korean are very
hard for non native speakers to learn just
in that,
in that six hours a day.
Some of the successful Chinese dual
language programs continue until five
o'clock in the afternoon, particularly
for writing. That's difficult for Spanish.
I think non native speakers come
out doing, you know, pretty well.
Um, and there's also a, um,
uh, like everything else,
there's a range of quality.
Some of them, it's just sort of
a little smattering the language.
You'll learn to sing some
songs. Um, others are, you
really learn to write and spell and speak
about science and the second language.
So there's a arranged there.
So it's one o'clock.
I think we have to wrap up,
so thank you so much.
[inaudible].